well i got it completely wrong in 2016
but if you look at the data it seems
clear that
vice president biden is quite a long way
ahead all of the data i can see
points to his victory but
burned by 2016 no one is saying that
they're going to put their head on the
block and
absolutely guarantee it if joe biden
does win
as the polls suggest would that actually
be good news for the united kingdom do
you think he values the special
relationship
i think he values the uk but he's a
serious person
who will follow the power and what he
knows is that when it comes to
the coveted crisis when it comes to the
climate challenge which he's put very
high on the agenda
when he comes to some of the major
global issues he can see that in paris
in berlin and in brussels you've got 27
countries working closely together
and there's no question in my mind that
for the biden camp
brexit has reduced the influence of the
uk
so yes he will be uh warm towards the uk
um but he will also be very realistic
about the kind of issues that we are
still struggling with
and about his urgency for getting things
done
and so i think that puts a special
premium on the british government
not just to get the trade deal with the
european union but also to sort
out the ways in which we are going to
cooperate on security terms on
intelligence terms on foreign policy
terms
with the european union which is
something that really has made
so little progress and that really
leaves us in a weaker position
so it's interesting is that because
biden's course has said that he
would have voted remain he said that
he's regretted the decision do you think
that he
may actually value other european
partners ahead of the uk then
well i think that when it comes to
something like the climate challenge the
european union
is a one of the top three global players
european union america china
are the deciders on the climate change
the european union's
set out a trillion euro plan for
decarbonizing the european
economy that's a major plank of the
biden promise and he wants to see that
as a way of engaging the chinese
as well now britain is hosting the
conference of the parties
to the un convention in november that's
an important element of our diplomacy
but the danger obviously is that we're
there
organizing the meeting but not actually
making the decision
should we really be hoping for a donald
trump victory then i mean he's somebody
who's been much more supportive of
brexit
he's talked about the value of the
special relationship he's also said that
the united kingdom would be at the front
of the queue
for that all-important trade deal
i mean it's interesting because we can
now judge president trump on actions not
just words and
i don't think anyone believes that he's
anything other than
utterly transactional in the way he does
his
business and what we know from the last
year
since the transition from our membership
of the european union started what we
know from the
four years since the referendum uh when
he's been president
is that the eeu us trade deal is going
nowhere for a very simple reason
the needs and the values and the
interests of british consumers
are incompatible with the needs values
and interests of american agriculture
that's just a massive stumbling block
it's the reason why there isn't a eu
us trade deal as well as a uk u.s trade
deal
so i think in the event of a trump
victory the big question for britain
becomes
does he really mean what he says about
neglecting nato does he really mean what
he says about confrontation with china
in every area of international life
because obviously
the current british government has set
out positions on a range of issues that
aren't the same
as the trump uh position and so i think
that if
president trump is re-elected then
democratic countries in europe are going
to find some big questions about how
they engage internationally when the u.s
doesn't want to engage
multilaterally at the same time they're
going back to the all-important
uk u.s trade deal one of the priorities
of course
for any british government working with
the new president at least with donald
trump we've got someone who says that he
wants to make it happen
putting us at the front of the queue
with joe biden all of the same obstacles
would remain
but he's also raised concerns over
things such as the internal markets bill
we know
as you say he's not a fan of brexit
either and he's not
exactly you would say a natural ally of
boris johnson so from that perspective
do you think a trade deal would be more
likely under donald trump
look my experience of this is that
these leaders they in the end work with
the hand that they're dealt
whatever president biden if he becomes
president biden's views of
the british prime minister he's going to
deal with him in a respectful and
serious way so i wouldn't get
too much caught up in the personality
politics i do think there are questions
for the prime minister
about how he shows that he can be a real
partner
talking about those global issues uh
donald trump of course has been
criticized for his foreign policy but at
the same time
he stood up to china he has engaged with
north korea
all of this without starting a war
unlike other previous presidents that
you could think of
should he not be given a bit more credit
i think that the credit for president
trump
is that he's done what he said he would
do he said he had no interest
in international multilateral alliances
and he's shown he meant it by pulling
out of the paris agreement
he said that he was going to make others
pay for things rather than america pay
for it he's followed through on that he
said he doesn't believe in climate
change and he's
shown that by pulling out of the climate
i don't have to agree with those things
but i think that's where if you want to
offer quote-unquote
credit in your word you'd offer that i
think though a sober-minded assessment
would also say
iran is closer to a nuclear weapon today
than it was four years ago
the north korean engagement has not led
to progress
and when it comes to engagement with
china obviously american
farmers and consumers have paid the
price of the tariffs that have
come in and china is actually in a much
stronger position
today than it was four years ago now i'm
keen to
ask you as well about anti-semitism
because of course this is the week
in which the equality and human rights
commission found the labour party had
acted
unlawfully when dealing with complaints
of anti-semitism
how shameful is this for labour
you can't think of anything more
shameful really than to
be found to be colluding conniving in in
what is essentially racist
um behavior or actions and so this is
this is painful this is shameful
as kiyosama said i think he used that
word for every member of the
labour party and it's a stain that has
to be
erased with absolute drive and
determination
and so i think that i reflect on the
fact i never felt
that when i was a member of parliament
for south shields or when i was
foreign secretary no one said oh he's a
jewish member of
parliament he's a jewish foreign
secretary and
what's happened in the labour party
after jeremy corbyn
got elected was that a series of people
came in or felt empowered
to be able to challenge people on the
basis of tropes about their
religion which is an absolute disgrace
and
i think it must be an absolutely central
part of public life to challenge that
and that seems to me what
a kierst armor is now doing but it's
work in progress as jeremy corbyn's
response to the
ehrc report on thursday showed
is it right that jeremy corbyn has been
suspended
yes definitely i mean jeremy corbyn's
response
showed all of the blindness all of the
arrogance all of the sticking of your
fingers in your ears
that we'd seen in his time as leader and
essentially he suspended himself
from the labor party and from the labour
whip in the house of commons i think he
he put himself beyond the pale and it's
essential that he shows that he's
willing to come within the pale
what i suppose i'm struggling to get my
head around is that
jeremy corbyn is now no longer fit to be
a labour mp he's been suspended because
of his reaction
why was it that members of the shadow
cabinet were less than a year ago
campaigning for him to be prime minister
asking people to
give them their vote i mean there's
nothing essentially new
in the report is there do you think the
shadow cabinet need to be taking
or the former shadow cabinet people like
kirsten now need to be taking
a hard look at why they didn't do more
well i think that the report did
actually
say some new things and show some new
things about political
uh interference so i don't think it's
important not to downgrade
the report i also think that the way
gear and angela rainer have been
speaking so plainly
this week about their reflections on the
past
only speaks well for them i mean the
truth about the jeremy corbyn
leadership is that he was never going to
get elected as
a prime minister we fear that he would
get slaughtered in
2017 um but he was just defeated
although
many seats were held by a fraction and
he was slaughtered in
like 2019 with the worst result that
labour has had since 1935 but
he was never going to get elected as a
prime minister but it was essential
to get as many labour mps who are able
to represent their
constituents and so i think this is a
moment when it's time for
the kind of steely determination the
steely leadership that kiyosama has
shown
to be supported and i think that's what
i sense
around things i think i mean i've
obviously not
come from a position of the hard left in
my politics i've always been
more on the center left and i've had
disagreements with those on the hard
left
but never in my worst thoughts that i
think that the hill that they would
choose to fight on
would be the hill of anti-semitism i
mean that's a they put themselves beyond
the pale
and i think the hard questions frankly
are for them at the same time though
um you say that kirstar and angela arena
have been
shown that steely leadership now
speaking out now but they still
campaigned
for jeremy corbyn to be prime minister
at a time when although we may not have
known all the details we did know that
there were issues over the way the
labour party had dealt with
anti-semitism i mean would you have
served in his shadow cabinet
well i'm afraid that there's very little
chance that he would have asked me to
serve in his
government so i can honestly say that is
a question i've never really had to
uh focus uh on i mean the i don't think
he wanted anything to do
with uh people of my political
uh stripe and that's one of the problems
of his of his leadership was the
sectarianism
that he applied to it so i think this
isn't really about
me this is about learning a very simple
lesson and frankly it links to the biden
conversation we're having we're having
if you have a candidate who attracts
people you can win elections and put
your values into practice
if you have a candidate like jeremy
corbyn who repels voters you've got no
chance
of being able to put your values into
practice
and that is the tragedy of british
politics over the last 10 years
obviously i was in a government which
was defeated
10 years ago at the polls and the
tragedy of the last
10 years is that from 2017 2019
british people felt they didn't have a
proper choice and
it must be right and it must be healthy
and it must be good not just for people
like me who are
members of the labour party but for the
country to have an opposition
that is worth its salt and that's what i
hope that pakistan will be able to bring
into practice